this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the weapons
from the winner of our most recent poll
the half-life franchise now the the
elephant in the room is always an
underbarrel grenade launcher on a
submachine gun that subsurd the MP5 made
lots of sense the grenade launcher made
almost no sense until I came to the
Royal armories and met this
if you like this kind of content we've
got a brand new season of Loadout airing
on the channel and you can check out our
most recent episode about the history
and pop culture impact of the M16 right
now right let's take a look at the
iconic weapons from half-life
[Music]
so first gun up is the Glock fond
memories of uh of using this I think
it's the first game I ever played well
definitely the first game I ever played
to try to replicate a Glock and if we
look at a real generation two Glock 17
you can clearly see that's what they're
going for uh despite the limitations of
the graphics we've got even got the um
the point on the front of the trigger
guard here bottom Edge General blocky
shape of course is uh is iconically
Glock so I wouldn't be surprised if they
haven't taken a photo of a Glock and
de-rezzed it and wrapped it onto the
actual model minor Quirk of the Glock in
the game and I think they did this just
because they could so they weren't just
inserting a black square into a black
square is the magazine to the real Glock
magazine that really is just a
apparently from the outside lump of
plastic the mag in the game is very
skinny and has Windows in it it looks a
lot like a mackerel magazine funnily
enough which has a very long witness
window so you can see how many rounds
you have left probably the the main
departure from the actual block design
[Laughter]
okay that's a surprise I did not expect
a locker with my name on it and a
picture of me in it in Half-Life does
even if there's even a very low poly
copy of my book
that's very cool
well you get points
all right so we've got black Mesa uh the
band remake remember rightly of the
Glock next and it is way more glocky
it's safe to say got lots of detail like
the um whereas there's just like a
square inset in the the back of the
slide on the original engine version of
the game this has the ribbed polymer
back plate of a real clock with the
different shapes the u-shaped version of
the rear sight that's on this Gen 2
clock and it just it's model better it
acts more realistically the magazines
look like Glock magazines it's just
better all around really
[Music]
right we're into Half-Life 2. the
pistol's been replaced by an HMK USP
match this is not a pistol unlike the
Glock from the original game that would
have just been lying around it's a
specialist competition variant of not a
she's not a hugely Gucci pistol but um
but the one with the competition muzzle
weight slash comp on the end of it is
pretty Gucci so a little bit surprising
and it's not something you're going to
keep finding in this environment if you
found one that would be it and you'd be
finding different guns it's pretty good
The Recoil seems excessive shouldn't
really be jumping around as much as it
is in terms of the detail of the model I
don't have one to show you but the it
should be cut away there should be a
U-shaped channel in the compensator the
big chunky bit on hanging off the front
of the gun so that the barrel which has
to recoil to operate the gun isn't
impeded and also it doesn't affect the
accuracy by contacting the barrel of the
pistol so the it's sits around the
barrel like this it's open on the top
it's not on this version probably
because they only had side profile
images to work from
uh the half-life shotgun um
simultaneously one of the most
satisfying shotguns in a video game and
one of the more irritating for gun nerds
because as I'm sure some of you know
it's a pretty much as fast 12 very very
closely based for the graphics of the
time anyway on that gun and inexplicably
it fires its alternate fire double
barrel shots out of the magazine tube
this is a closed off tube it houses your
shotgun cartridges it's how they go
backwards into the action pours into the
chamber and get fired standard tube fed
shotgun arrangement for a very
non-standard convertible from pump to
semi-automatic exotic shotgun it's
conventional in the sense of the
magazine tube um developers either
didn't know or didn't care how shotguns
worked and so they went oh two tubes may
as well give it two shots but when
you're actually playing the game it's
pretty damn satisfying to lose off the
the double double barrel so they wanted
to have their cake and eat it too as far
as the actual model goes it's not as
close to the smash 12 as I remember I
mean it has the double the double tube
um it has the pretty close shape of the
at the fore end the rest of it is a
little bit far removed actually they've
kind of foreshortened the whole gun so
that the the bolts and ejection Port
area on the receiver is shunted forward
into the heat shield area and the
basically this whole bit is missing this
bit shunted forward the whole design is
changed up interesting I've not seen the
gun fired from a third person's use side
on like that and when the double barrels
are fired there is markedly more recoil
animated into the gun yeah the doubled
up sound effect sounds very impressive
devastating effect on the Target and the
gun rising up to imply power
all right
so I've not played Black Mesa and I've
not seen their take on the shotgun it's
substantially closer to this fast 12.
proportions are more correct shape of
the well the shape of the whole thing is
more correct it's got the um release
catch on this side modeled in as well I
think what we've done is model a spouse
12 but to make it fit the aesthetic of
Half-Life where it's not quite the same
gun they've added in attachment to the
upper receiver which is also giving it a
a rail on the top we still got the same
double shot for alt fire and if they've
tried to model the magazine shoe with an
open muzzle as though it is a second
barrel and they also didn't want to
change the gameplay too much so we still
have our old fire nice touch in the
recoil is that not only we're seeing
more recoil it's actually coming out of
the support and which really emphasizes
that you're firing an awful lot of lead
down range
all right
oh this is this was an incredibly cool
weapon in 1998 I think it still is
that's a pretty massive prod the actual
arms on the on the bow they look pretty
substantial and the effect on the
enemies implies something relatively
powerful any crossbow you can [__] by
just pulling back on the string isn't
going to be hugely powerful you can ramp
up the power with cams which aren't on
this strips of what look to be steel and
then some sort of composite you'd have a
job to do that traditional crossbows and
one in particular the Chinese repeating
crossbow so in that case you could [__]
it by hand without using a a windlass or
a cranicain and it has a magazine of
quarrels just like this does only it
feeds using Gravity from the top for
this to work the way this does it would
need to replicate what a firearm does
with a spring not impossible but um the
Chinese did it with gravity feet which
makes a lot of sense considering it just
needs to drop onto the groove
forgive me I'm not a curator of uh of
archery the scope I guess gave this a
bit more of a sort of modern tactical
feel and and obviously affects the
gameplay directly as well
foreign
upgrade for black Mesa they have put
those cams in on the prod there to uh I
guess modernize it a bit but otherwise
the design is is pretty close to the
original bolts look funnily enough more
like this more like they might be
explodey but they're not they're just
um the physics of the game I guess
different engine have them knock the
target back with a hell of a lot of
force far too much force it has to be
said although a crossbow bolt or quarrel
or an arrow is a quite a massive object
compared to uh to most bullets it still
doesn't have enough Mass to physically
knock you down and certainly knock you
head over heels like that and it's
traveling way slower than the bullet as
well
[Music]
oh
okay this rendition uh it's half life
two crossbow is looking well very
different design wise it looks to be
entirely homemade as the scope of the
original but the we've lost the magazine
we're now single loading some sort of
metal rod that is being super heated by
I guess a battery or capacitor or
something that's on the weapon well I
don't know why you're superheating a
projectile heating heating up a
projectile doesn't really achieve very
much but it certainly looks cool sounds
cool and the ability to pin the enemies
to the background is looks like a lot of
fun I have to say it really looks very
very powerful very effective limited by
the reduced capacity over the original
right so although I'm uh MP5 obsessed as
some of you know probably my favorite
gun in the original Half-Life game was
the Magnum this is the python
I mean not sure the graphics are quite
good enough to be able to say for sure
which precise model it is but um for me
it was a python I don't think I was
aware of the cold Anaconda at the time
this should be about the right barrel
length obviously six shots double action
real really Punchy sound effects high
damage it's not been sort of fudged in
the design so it has the it has the
culch uh classic pullback and the shape
of the cylinder latch uh shape of the
trigger guard the barrel shroud it's all
it's all very cult and it functions you
know pretty much like a like it ought to
do just a great video game gun there's
not much I can say about it I've no real
criticisms uh certainly not for the not
for the the time okay here's one the way
the rear sights depicted as being part
of the frame and very open at the back
is is not right revolver sights for
these guns uh yeah okay the notch is
quite wide because the front side is
proportionately wide
but um if there's a compromise made
it's probably with that
now with a graphical overhaul we get a
closer closer rendition although the top
strap if this is the pipe still a python
the top strap is not the right shape but
this uh the rear sight being an insert
that's well the real gun is adjustable
not obviously not on the real on the um
virtual one but the configuration is
closer to reality we do have a what
looks like an axis pin for the hammer
that doesn't exist it's not visible on
the left side of the real gun it is on
the right side in fact yeah looking at
that we have two two pins that have been
I guess probably mirrored on both sides
of the frame and then the latch has just
been put on on one side so a slight
compromise it does have the night sight
or all the high Vis I should say plastic
insert on the front sight blade and it
has uh glowing presumably tritium dots
on the rear sight which you could
replicate on this by changing the
changing out the rear sight this has the
standard u-shaped white notch
all right
foreign
with sights option which is very nice
couldn't do that with the original game
and I see now that in fact both sides of
the gun are mirrored so there's a
cylinder latch and these pins that only
appear on the on one only appears on the
left side the other only appears on the
right side on both sides a common labor
and time saving device to just mirror
both sides of the gun because who's
gonna care really nice animation of
flicking out the cylinder which I won't
do on this because I don't want to
damage the gun in any way uh that's cool
uh the whole all the animations the
reload animation is is way Superior of
course however it does not show
operating the cylinder latch in order to
open the cylinder it's just flick it out
put it back in minor realism issue there
getting very very nerdy here but for the
most part cult revolvers rotate their
cylinder clockwise as from the from the
point of view of the user
see that happening there
and Smith Wesson rotate counterclockwise
and although this is supposed to be a
cult it's rotating the Smith and Wesson
way around and I think that might be the
nerdiest gun comment I've I've made I'm
sure I've made nerdier
thank you
okay so I think I'm getting my
chronology slightly uh mixed up in that
black mice comes after Half-Life 2 as a
remake of Half-Life one so the revolver
in Black Mesa is based on the one in
half like two that I'm now looking at
what we have got in Half-Life 2 that we
didn't in Black Mesa is a nod toward the
cylinder latch however they're pushing
it like with Smith and Wesson rather
than pulling it
as in occult system
right this is a this is a quirky bit of
video game gun history in that when I
first first played Half-Life the iconic
MP5 with underbarrel grenade launcher
was was the perhaps the most memorable
weapon in the game now the the elephant
in the room is always an underbarrel
grenade launcher on a submachine gun
that's absurd the MP5 made lots of sense
the grenade launcher made almost no
sense until I came to the Royal armories
and met this
saw it on the wall and just almost
literally boggled somebody had made a
launcher for an MP5 I don't know I think
I then tried to rationalize it and go I
must be a flare launcher nope this is I
mean it may not just have been for
lethal purpose but primarily it's a it's
a 40 millimeter grenade launcher for an
MP5 almost identical to the half-life
gun so this is incredibly cool it's just
played by a UK company called istec and
was sort of shopped around along with a
version for full-length rifles and short
story long story short well not very
long story shorter still wasn't
successful wasn't sold as far as I know
there's no firing mechanism modeled on
the gun if remember rightly but on the
real thing you have to reach under here
and it is a
double action trigger which is pretty
common for for ugls so there we are the
half-life MP5 kind of exists if you'd
like to find out more about this uh we
will have uh Royal armories
um what is this weapon video up by now
where you can get a little bit more
information on this
thank you
our remade MP5 so having had I think it
was blue shift retcon the MP5 into a
different gun we have in this remake
gone back to the MP5 great love the MP5
we've got Picatinny I picatinny rail
four end that's also adapted to take
what must be a truncated version of the
m203 we've got a full set of reload
animations that were missing from the
original game we've got a not the HK
slap we have the look it out of the
notch with your thumb approach which is
okay and we see Gordon reach into the uh
trigger the trigger guard of the grenade
launcher to actually fire it something
I've Just Seen there that I think was
also true of the original game is that
the grenades come flying out of the
barrel tumbling in reality this uh or
the m203 and this are both
rifles and if you can see the rifling in
the bore there and it flies it's a giant
essentially the 40 40 by 46 grenade
round is a giant cartridge so it should
fly straight and true because it's
spinning in that way it's not tumbling
through the air if that's happening
something's gone horribly wrong with
your launcher and you're not gonna have
the accuracy you need to try to place uh
the round
expect
Ed all right this is wacky as heck for
someone like me that hasn't played
halfway too however um I have two
confused observations firstly and most
confusingly how the hell is this
launching a grenade at least the MP5 had
a launcher modeled onto it in in
Half-Life one there's nowhere for a
grenade to come out of so I have no idea
I must be missing something I think I'll
try and keep an eye out and the other
thing is the shape of the thing the
pistol grip is too far back and that's
what we have here it's pretty close to
an MP7 but the whole pistol grip with
the magazine is all the way back here
which means there's no room for the bolt
to actually reciprocate and feed rounds
it could not work which is weird because
there's a lot of detail from the MP7 on
this model though they've modeled this
from life as it were in fact you can see
when it's shaft
the arms of the stock are modeled
alongside
the gun there is this hint of a second
Barrel under the under the main Barrel
but there's nowhere it's nowhere near
big enough for a grenade round really
quite a curious gun
now this brings back a lot of memories
the original Half-Life rocket launcher
extremely cool in just about every way
including the
um quite faithful uh representation of a
recordless weapon with a rocket assisted
projectile where say you have that
launch from from expelling chart and
then the rocket motor firing up
obviously somewhat cartoony by real life
standards but kind of how they actually
work I didn't automatically know this
but uh someone else quite rightly has
identified what I think rightly has
identified this the armbrust launcher
which is a recoiler is a recordless
weapon looks a heck of a lot like the
half-life launcher uh mainly in this
front end but also in a few other design
cues I think it's safe to say that
somebody spotted this in I don't know
copy of Jane's infantry ones or
something and base the launcher on this
because it's not particularly well known
the black Mesa remake is pretty much
fitting the theme of all the others it's
the same basic weapon enhanced there's a
little little display screen I didn't
see that doing anything just more detail
overall really no no change to to
functionality they haven't tried to make
it more like an armbrust I think it
might lose a little bit of punch in the
way they've sort of moderated the delay
it's not quite as satisfying
I'm doing impressions of weapons on
camera now
Half-Life 2's rocket launcher we've got
some changes here looks more like an 84
equipment hanging underneath is to do
with the later guidance so they're not
sure what they're still not sure what
the big green cylinder is there for but
the main thing up front there is your
grip stock it's not a million miles away
from from this setup on the on the um
inspiration for the original Half-Life
weapon but they've built they've done I
guess a better job of showing you where
your laser guidance system is although
the main webiness there would have to be
built into the the Warhead to be able to
communicate with the weapon and steer
onto Target which is a in Broad terms a
real functionality that exists for
anti-tank weapons
well there isn't much expertise I can
bring to bear on the angry alien bee gun
which I remember pretty clearly from
from the original game either didn't I
don't remember all possibly never even
realized that this was actually well
it's obviously the arm of an alien
actually but I haven't realized that you
were shoving your own hand up the arm
it's a little bit uh David Cronenberg
seen in profile attached to your arm
like that
oh
this is a really weird one I'd heard of
the combine assault rifle never actually
seen it in use so this is this is a
first it's really strange so it's
feeding it's got a sort of motorized
like an or like a tank Auto loader
system to get around more of a magazine
really into the chamber
straight into the barrel I don't know
and then some it's hugely bulky at the
back and yet all the action is happening
at the front it's like the mullet of of
video game guns and then some sort of
massive firing pin is just slapping the
back of the magazine thing and it then
sounds like and works basically like a
normal rifle kind of exciting and
disappointing all at the same time but
the disappointment is obliterated when
the alt fire is used and it's not clear
to me where that's coming from it's a
separate ammunition pool which then
bounces around the room and vaporizes
stuff which and you kind of go ah
there's the half-life
oh
all right that seems to work all right
we are back to a game that I have played
albeit only only about a third of I'm I
was quite surprised that the gun was
really old school in terms of being a
1911 pattern handgun with some weird
future changes I think something I did
appreciate about the the route this game
took with the handgun is that you're
almost replicating the experience of a
movie armorer certainly one from the 80s
90s where they're taking a base gun in
this case a 1911 and then they're
disguising it with sci-fi stuff where in
this game you start with pretty much a
1911 with a couple of bells and whistles
and then you are doing making those
changes to make it more sci-fi so I
don't think that's what they were trying
to go for but it's a frame of reference
that I bring to the table and I thought
it was quite a cool cool aspect
oh
all right
this shotgun or shock pistol is really
odd in this game a lot of thoughts gone
into the the look of it it's quite
industrial but sci-fi at the same time
sort of look the mechanism for breaking
it open it's kind of weird that a
shotgun like this would break open I
don't think there's any reasonable way
in which this could feed and work we've
got a a slightly weird double load I'm
sure you've seen certainly in John Wick
multiple rounds being loaded in one go
so you hold two or even four in your
hand and shove them all into the tube
and here we've got um Alex holding two
like a syringe and shoving them into the
magazine that way I think I understand
the the in-game justification for having
this be a such a short weird shotgun
with such a weird mechanism and that is
that they made this the decision to make
all the weapons one-handed so you've
always got a free hand to interact with
other stuff in VR and you're not
constrained by having to sort of lock
your hands together to a two-handed gun
I must admit as a enthusiastic of these
things
um I would prefer to be able to have the
two-handed aiming experience
right those were the guns of the
half-life series I hope you enjoyed
those I know I did as always there are
ways that you can support the work that
we do here at the Royal armories Museum
we have our various social media outlets
and our own YouTube channel which
includes a fair bit of yours truly as
does an event coming up on the 11th of
March
um where you can actually depending on
which ticket you purchase see our
website or social media for details um
you can actually come and say hello to
me whatever you do join us again next
time for another one of these
[Music]
thank you